- Hi, I'm Meaghan from Khan Academy,
and I'm here to share
more about the content
available on Khan Academy.
When we talk about
content on Khan Academy,
what we really mean is
all the videos, articles
and practice questions that
learners interact with.
We think about all of those
as split into two categories.
The videos and articles
are instructional content,
and the practice questions
are practice content.
Taken together, our goal
is to provide learners
with the ability to learn about anything
they might encounter in
a K through 12 classroom
and then practice what they've learned.
A key part of that practice
is that they'll get instant feedback
about how they're doing.
Along with work solutions to
help them get back on track
if they're not quite clear
on a particular concept.
In this video we'll explain the content
we offer for teachers and students
and what makes it special.
We know many people are familiar
with Khan Academy's great math content.
But people are often unaware
that the Khan Academy
has more than math.
People might be surprised to learn
that we've recently
launched a beta version
of our new English Language Arts content.
Our goal is to eventually cover
all core academic subjects K through 14.
We aren't there yet,
but if you haven't explored beyond math,
there are dozens of other courses
in the sciences, finance and economics
and arts and humanities.
We also have test prep content
including free official SAT practice,
created in partnership with College Board,
and official Praxis Core prep,
developed in collaboration with ETS.
We absolutely have not
forgotten about math though.
We recently published a series
of Get ready for grade level
math courses for 3rd
grade to pre-calculus,
to best prepare students
for on-grade level courses.
If you are looking to learn something new,
you can view all of our courses
by clicking the dropdown
menu in the top left
of the Khan Academy website.
You can also find content to
support learning a new skill
by using our search function
to search by skill name or by
Common Core State Standard.
Khan Academy's content is
organized into courses.
Most of our courses are divided into units
and within every unit
are multiple lessons.
Lessons include instructional
and practice resources,
such as videos, articles and exercises.
In many courses quizzes combine practice
from several preceding lessons.
Units end with a test
that checks understanding
of the entire unit.
Khan Academy has a lot of
content created by a team
of former teachers and
subject matter experts.
Our team ensures that all of
this content is high quality
by partnering with leading
educational organizations
and external experts to
make sure our content
is up to date and genuinely
aligned to standards.
For math, in collaboration
with external reviewers,
we also tag all content
with regards to rigor
to be sure we are appropriately balancing
conceptual, procedural
and application content.
As teachers we know you have many options
when it comes to using
tools in your classroom.
So you might be asking yourself,
"What makes Khan
Academy's content unique?"
Well, Khan Academy's
content is interactive.
We have questions that
ask students to read
and interpret maps, images,
audio and text passages.
We have interactive charts and graphs
to teach students to
read and interpret data
with a variety of
different question types.
Consider exploring our
content to sample the variety
of practice questions we offer.
Our content gives instant feedback.
After answering any
question, students will learn
is they are corrects or incorrect.
Students who are stuck on a problem
will be provided with support,
such as related videos and articles,
hints for solution strategies
and rationales that explain
why a particular answer
is correct or incorrect.
We've heard some teachers
ask if Khan Academy's content
is student friendly.
Our content is definitely
students friendly
and encourages a growth mindset
by letting students know
that they can learn anything.
We want students to feel
like they're receiving
personalized support.
We model thinking processes
that we hope students will use
as they ask questions and solve problems.
We hope this video provides
a look into the content
available on Khan Academy.
But we know the best way to
learn more is to experience it.
Choose a topic that inspires
you and explore it firsthand.